ce weekend le vélodrome national de 50
ans en ivine va accueillir des épreuves
de BMX Freestyle pour parler de cet
événement à mes côtés à Nicolas André
qui travaille à la Fédération française
de cyclisme et lor Pez qui sera athlète
sur la compétition alors Lori comment ça
se passe dans votre tête à quelques
jours de l'épreuve ben c'est super cool
parce que on est là au Vélodrome et
c'est vraiment le centre du cyclisme
quoi donc j'ai vraiment hâte de mettre
mes premières roues sur le skate park et
et de tout donner quoi vous venez à
peine d'arriver hein c'est ça ouais je
suis arrivée hier et du coup pour
l'instant pas d'entraînementst non c'est
demain les premers le premier jour de
training c'est demain et la première
impression quand on voit ce vélodrome
national de de 50 ans en liveline c'est
impressionnant parce qu'il y a beaucoup
de de sièges autour donc on va on va
pouvoir avoir plein de public et tout et
le parc qui soit au milieu c'est
vraiment fou quoi il y aura il y aura
possibilité de faire des belles figures
j'imagine ouais avec les beaux modules
qu'on a là c'est vraiment cool Nicolas
André pourquoi organiser ce type
d'événement ici dans ce vodrome national
de cant en Yveline alors vous savez que
que la discipline du BMX Freestyle dont
la spécialité du du parc et olympique et
à 230 jours des Jeux de Paris 2024 on a
voulu mettre un bel écrin aussi à à tous
ces riders les mettre sous les feux des
projecteurs au sens propre comme figuré
on sera en indor c'est un peu inidit et
c'est une trajectoire
euh souhaité par la Fédération de les
mettre dans des conditions stables de
météo forcément si si la pluie venait
sur le parc ça devient dangereux voire
impraticable et nous on a voulu les
mettre en lumière sous sous ce vélodrome
national à quelques mois des Jeux pour
les dans les meilleures conditions les
sélections olympiques court ils doivent
bien se préparer et et pas se blesser et
et préparer l'échéance majeure que sont
les jeux en France c'est un défi pour
vous d'organiser ce type d'événement ici
dans ce vélodrome national de 50
Anseline oui c'est un défi puisque un
vélodrome national c'est la discipline
Ren c'est c'est la piste c'est fait pour
ça c'est c'est conçu pour ça et j'espère
que le public a été attiré on voit que
les ventes de billetteries augmentent
tous les jours et attiré par ce côté
atypique de venir mettre des modules de
parc en centre-piste bien sûr il y aura
aussi le flat qui est non olympique mais
qui décernera aussi des titres de
champion de France ce weekend et
j'espère que Ben comme l'a dit Lori le
public appréciera le spectacle de ce
weekend vous attendez environ combien de
personnes pour cet événement alors à ce
jour au moment où on se parle on a 1000
personnes qui seront là sur la journée
du samedi qui sont les phases de qualif
iation et on est à 2000 personnes
dimanche il y a encore de la place il y
aura de la vente sur place on a des
tarifs très attractifs 5 € pour les
cantinois et nos licenciés FFC et 10 €
pour pour tout le reste du public et
bien sûr venez nombreux il y aura de la
place pour vous pour apprécier le
spectacle plus de 1000 personnes c'était
l'objectif ou pas de de base oui c'est
ça on a on a une jauge à 2500 personnes
on y est presque et pour les finales ben
ben toutes les places sont prises pour
venir encourager ces titulaires de
l'équipe de France les autres
compétiteurs et leur apporter tout le
soutien dans cette phase de préparation
olympique c'était un défi ou pas
d'organiser cette compétition ici oui
c'est c'est un défi comme je vous l'ai
dit souvent ils sont habitués à évoluer
en outdoor et nous on a souhaité les
mettre dans des conditions stables
surtout la période où on est en décembre
ça aurait été risqué de de faire ça en
extérieur et rentrer ses modules monter
ses module avec l'activité dense du
Vélodrome c'est un défi en soi puisque
le début du montage a commencé
lundi et il va se terminer tard dans la
nuit et demain pour les premers training
à 14h tout sera en place Lauri il y aura
environ 90 athlètes sur cette
compétition est-ce que le niveau sera
élevé sur cette compétition euh bah oui
le niveau va être élevé forcément parce
que on a tous les meilleurs Français qui
vont venir faire l'épreuve donc plus
c'est un championnat de France donc ça
va se ça va se motiver et il en aura
vraiment du beau spectacle une
compétition que vous avez vous-même
remporté dans le passé vous allez
remettre votre titre en jeu pas trop de
stress justement ben forcément il y en a
toujours parce que ben on a le stress de
remettre en en jeu notre titre mais
avant tout il y a le plaisir d'être sur
notre vélo donc faut d'abord faut
d'abord ben apprécier apprécier ça quoi
quel est votre style à vous sur sur
votre vélo euh ben j'aime bien faire des
figures aller haut tout ça votre préféré
ma figure ou le backflip backflip
pourquoi ça fait plein de sensation
c'est cool quoi on a la tête à l'envers
c'est cool c'est aussi spectaculaire à
Nicolas André ce cette discipline ce
c'est du jamais vu ici dans ce vélodrome
national de
ans en Yveline c'est aussi ça l'objectif
ça attire un nouveau public oui je je
pense que comme je le disais avec cinq
disciplines olympiques on en a quatre
qui sont chronométré les classiques et
celle-là elle est jugée elle est
spectaculaire
elle est aux Jeux Olympiques tout le
monde n'a encore pas intégré je pense le
fait que que le BMX Freestyle qui est
récent au programme des jeux pour le
parc et au programme olympique et c'est
aussi une volonté de la fédération de
faire connaître ces disciplines qui sont
reconnues olympiqu et qui je l'espère
vont rester au programme des Jeux
pendant longtemps ce véodrome national a
l'habitude d'accueillir de grandes
compétitions notamment du cyclisme sur
piste avec des championnats du monde des
championnats d'Europe est-ce qu'à
l'avenir on pourrait voir d'autres
compétitions organisées ici sur ce
vélodrome national de 550 an ivelin oui
la communauté d'agglomération de C50
yvelin utilise et commercialise ce
vélodrome pour des activités en
centre-piste diverses et varié on voit
que d'autres euh sport évoluent au
centrepiste du tennis de table du
badminton et et nous on avait jamais osé
mettre une discipline du cyclisme en
centrepiste ces choses faites dimanche
soir et puis j'espère que ça laissera un
souvenir ind délébil à la fois au rider
mais aussi aux spectateurs et
téléspectateurs puisqu'on sera en direct
télé pour les finales dimanche le BMX
Freestyle ça plaît beaucoup aussi au
public jeune c'est aussi l'objectif
peut-être d'attirer un nouveau public
ici au Vélodrome national oui euh avec
le l'accent chantant de de laori on voit
que c'est une discipline plutôt on va
dire du Sud on sait qu'il y a beaucoup
de riders on va dire free euh sur la
région parisienne et l'ambition de la
Fédération c'est de les embarquer dans
un cadre fédéral euh qui prennent des
licences et qui a une base plus solide
pour évoluer à haut niveau et et espérer
avoir euh voilà des des adversaires plus
nombreux pour laori et et récupérer
beaucoup de médailles au au plan
international que ça soit les jeux mais
aussi Championnat du Monde championnat
d'Europe laori est-ce que vous avez le
sentiment que votre discipline est en
plein essort oui ben ça a beaucoup
évolué depuis que c'est rentré au Geo et
oui c'est on sent que ça se développe de
plus en plus que ça devient de plus en
plus professionnel au niveau bah de
l'entraînement tout ça l'hygiène de vie
euh ça prend c'est beaucoup plus sérieux
qu'avant oui ou vous avez commencé le le
BMX il y a environ 9 ans si je si je me
trompe pas vous vous avez pu voir
l'évolution au fur et à mesure des
années c'est beaucoup plus structuré
encadré ouais ça rien à voir avec avant
oui l'avenir s'annonc r Dieu pour le BMX
Freestyle vous AZ sentiment là ou ouais
ça va vraiment évoluer ça va être bien
vous êtes d'accord Nicolas André je suis
complètement d'accord je crois que que
l'avenir olympique est tout ouvert pour
ces discipline spectaculaire nouvelle le
CEO en faisant rentrer le le skate le
BMX Park se trompe pas et je pense qu'on
attire des nouveaux spectateurs du du du
programme olympique et que B ça va ça va
perdurer et faire grandir le niveau de
pratique les pratiquants et le niveau
aussi sportif pour que la France
atteigne les sommets laori vous faites
partie de ces têtes d'affiches qui
seront présentes ici au Vélodrome
national sur le weekend vous quels sont
vos objectifs dans cette discipline je
crois qu'il y a une compétition un peu
médiatique qui arrivera dans les
prochains mois les Jeux Olympiques
est-ce que c'est votre objectifou oui
c'est mon objectif principal c'est
vraiment de participer de pouvoir
décrocher une médaille c'est vraiment
l'objectif mon plus objectif quoi c'est
réalisable c'est ouais avec de
l'entraînement c'est réalisable c'est
dur mais on va tout faire pour Nicolas
André le mot de la fin peut-être avec
vous est-ce qu'on peut vous avez dit
qu'il restait encore des places comment
ça se passe si on veut venir ici au
Vélodrome national de 50 ans en liveline
alors la vente se passe en ligne vous
pouvez acheter jusqu'au dernier moment
bien sûr en ligne de façon aisée mais il
y aura aussi un guichet billetterie sur
place comme je l'ai dit je rappelle les
tarifs 5 € pour les
continois pour les licenciés pour les
étudiants sur présentation d'un
justificatif et 10 € pour tout le monde
il y a aussi un forfait weekend à 15 €
donc les ventes sont en ligne mais aussi
sur place venez nombreux ça va être un
très beau spectacle et pour les riders
c'est très important qui se sent
soutenus avant de rejoindre la Concorde
au mois d'août faut venir avec les
drapeaux français c'est ça le maquillage
les drapeaux et les encourager très fort
parce que comme l'a dit Lori l'objectif
c'est c'est les jeux et et c'est bientôt
merci à tous les deux bonne compétition
ce weekend on espère une victoire pour
vous Lori on se mouille un peu mais on
espère que vous serez sur la plus haute
marche du podium ce weekend merci merci
à tous les deux la compétition de BMX
Freestyle c'est ce weekend au Vélodrome
national de 50 ans en livbline